jetzt aber schön ist denn dann feiern
wir in dieser woche ja auch noch 15
jahre facebook herzlichen glückwunsch
beziehungsweise per pura täglich ein
drittel der erdenbewohner machen damit
facebook der knuffige familienbetrieb
aus kalifornien freut sich aktuell über
30 prozent umsatzsteigerung ja in
deutschland allerdings geht es gerade
steil bergab für die hiobsbotschaft
liebe facebook-gemeinde sie wissen dass
ich nun nicht mehr cdu-vorsitzende bin
und deshalb werde ich meine
facebook-seite schließen wir kleinen
heuchler was lese ich denn jetzt vorm
einschlafen aber gut so sind halt die
regeln müssen sie nur cdu-vorsitzende
dürfen bei facebook seite sie ist ja
noch bei instagram und wahrscheinlich
geht sie demnächst zusammen mit robert
habeck zurück zu studivz dass das
bundeskartellamt in bonn hat gestern
festgestellt und ich zitiere facebook
sei marktbeherrschend und missbrauche
seine stellung beim sammeln von daten
nur ein split haben sie das gewusst
meine damen und herren ja tatsächlich
und ohne witz machen wir user ist der
alten datenkrake aber auch ein bisschen
zu einfach
beunruhigt ich nicht dass dann die
ganzen daten immer landen oder für ewig
gespeichert sind ne gar nicht ist ja
ehrlich gesagt ziemlich schlampig mit
meinen daten um so mehr ist das komplett
egal so aber ich habe ehrlich gesagt
schon angst
ja klar und weil viele facebook kunden
hier so denken bleibt deutschland für
zuckerberg so was wieder daten eben muss
man ganz klar sagt ja entschuldigung für
das bild ja ja ich entschuldige mich
sonst
[Applaus]
ich wünschte ich könnte ihnen sagen wir
mussten ist aber das wäre gelogen haben
selbst wenn das kartellamt jetzt sagt
facebook darf nicht mehr ohne zu fragen
unsere daten von whats app instagram und
facebook zusammenführen ich fürchte ich
mach das trotzdem soziales netzwerk das
ist ein daten konzern ein monopolist und
wir alle sind die ware billige book ware
ja die fertigung meine daten weiter und
müssen dafür in deutschland so gut wie
keine steuern zahlen frankreich schauen
hier nicht man fragt sich wirklich kennt
diese firma überhaupt noch irgendwelche
skrupel soll nämlich das unternehmen
jugendliche dafür bezahlt haben ihren
gesamten datenverkehr offenzulegen
umgerechnet bis zu 18 euro im monat
sollen schon 13-jährige erhalten haben
für ihre gesamten chats fotos standorte
und mehr na ja die typen vor der schule
ihrer kinder sind nicht immer
drogendealer viele arbeiten auch für
facebook
hören wir auf mit facebook wird doch eh
nur quatsch gepostet schnitzel bilder
oder videos wie das hier ja
das slim wichtig
[Applaus]
so also angela merkel ist wir sprachen
darüber neuerdings nicht mehr bei
facebook dafür aber weiter als hippe
influence darin bei instagram 14 wenigen
themen mit denen ich mich leider so gar
nicht auskenne deswegen begrüße ich an
dieser stelle unsere heute-show netz
reporterin larissa
[Applaus]
bis 3
ein sogenannter
den titel native das heißt sie hat wlan
aber ansonsten absolut keine ausbildung
larissa larissa was halten sie denn von
frau merkels insta account ja kann sein
aber also als erstes möchte ich auf
jeden fall schon mal sagen vielen
herzlichen dank oliver dass ich heute
hier in das ein sehr interessanter ich
sag mal so erfahrung für mich dabei zu
sein in so eine alte leute sehen und
deswegen sehr geehrte liebe alte
menschen
ich finde es schön dass sie einen noch
wach sind
ja weil die brauchen sie eigentlich
häufig schlaf um sich vorzubereiten auf
den ton ja stimmt ja als berühmte foto
machen
klingt ja so können wir jetzt bitte
zurückkommen auf dem thema der tatsachen
weil meine zeit wechselt oft bäume sehr
schnittig ja also ich habe mir den
kompletten kurs von frau merkel einmal
sehr experte lang und das waren wirklich
die schönsten drei minuten von meinem
ganzen leben schwörer und du meine güte
ich habe so gewöhnt vor langeweile
ja ihr profil ist sehr professionell sie
benutzt nicht mal filter ja sie sieht
auf allen fotos mindestens auf sie 30
oder 40 euro
circus krone soja und krone nichts böses
und dann hatte ich übertreibe nicht auf
sechs bildern immer die gleiche route
nacken
das ist follower hygienisch ist sie
verrückt ich mein kann ja sein aber
trotzdem kann sie das machen ja und ich
verstehe auch die videos überhaupt
schaffen kann nähen englisch geht zum
beispiel da wirkt sie ein weißes
kälbchen und silber oder hierbei geht es
mit einem mann spazieren
ich nehme an das ist der ehemann ja ja
aber eigentlich finde ich schon sehr
witterung sehr gut dass sie dazu steht
weißt du dass dir sagt dir was ja und
mein mann ist von einer andere sagt man
ja also dass das ist quasi ein gelber
mann und des 1 kaiser von china und aber
ich stehe dazu will ich in liebe ja und
das finde ich sehr gut weil während 2018
den nazis ja und ich sehr glücklich von
der merkel außerdem herr oliver sie sagt
ganz oft auch sachen wo ich denke
tormann ab das habe ich so nicht gewusst
landwirtschaft ist von entscheidender
bedeutung
oder meine güte wusstest du dass herr
oliver landwirtschaft
es ist nämlich so alles was zu essen
haben landwirte gekocht ja auch den
gemüse ich hoffe gemüse wirklich aber es
ist sehr wichtig wegen vitamin e
das wusste ich alles nicht musik ist das
spinnennetz reporter rang
aber jetzt müssen wir noch unbedingt
ganz kurz über datenschutz reden ja
datenschutz leute ihr müsst so aufpassen
die großen firmen sie wohl alle eure
daten facebook kick getränke hoffmann
glaubt mir das mindeste ist ein gut
passwort wirklich du glaubst dass der
deutsche für thomas wolfer haben also my
love you ist jetzt nicht besonders
einfallsreich oder eins zwei drei vier
fünf oder sechs warum ist der kranke
aber egal er hat recht 1 2 3 4 5 1 4345
ich habe zb kann ich euch zeigen
ja
[Applaus]
ich habe noch einen trick ja vor allem
ganz ganz ganz wichtig ist nie das
gleiche passwort 2 x ich mach das so
mein facebook passwort ist zum beispiel
amazon um ein amazon passwort ist
facebook ich schwöre bekommen die nie
drauf so kann man deine mutter geht zum
hacken in den garten schwule unseren
[Applaus]